change gears here quickly to the New
York Giants because they addressed
yesterday the decision to fire head
coach patch trimmer but keep GM Dave
gentlemen here's the explanation from
Giants Cohen or John Mara on why Shermer
went but Gettleman is staying like I
said with Dave I think we've had some
hits and some misses he's implemented so
many changes within our organization we
just felt like at this stage to pull the
plug on all that would not be the wise
thing to do I'm excited about what I see
in the future for this team because of
the young players we have because of the
changes that we're making yeah and look
I don't know is it easy to reconcile is
it hard to reconcile blaming it on patch
Shermer not blaming it on Dave Gettleman
and also acknowledging that the presence
of Gettleman could limit your universe
of coaches now mat rule has said
positive things about Dave gentlemen in
the past Matt rule worked for the Giants
in 2012 while gediman was still there as
one of their top Scouts so there is a
relationship and if rules of their guy
rule would seem to be one of the guys
who wouldn't come in and say yeah I want
a different GM so maybe that's part of
the reasoning for it but it's it's a
delicate balance very Chris very so he
preys on Gettleman but say Shermer
should be fired because if you got a
young team well you're not gonna win a
lot of games but you're trying to build
something for the future and you could
argue enough was done this year to find
a reason to believe that Pat Shermer is
gonna turn the corner next year well I I
mean yeah I mean Pat Shermer of course
he talked about the talent on the
defense on his way out the door right
saying the defense was horrible
basically I'm paraphrasing but I mean
that was kind of a shot like we didn't
have very good players there what did
you want me to do as a head coach you
know I'm like I said yesterday I'm a
little torn with Dave gentlemen there's
a lot that I respect about it but I
would say you know hey it's two years in
the NFL two years in the NFL this is not
1984 anymore like teams get turned
around in two years and there really
wasn't much improvement of the team now
there's been some players where you go
who the future looks good yeah that's
awesome and Dave gentlemen like we
talked about yesterday the draft not bad
I guess where it really comes down to is
free agencies been some misses and they
didn't turn the corner and I think with
the Mara family tell
there yesterday is that they believe
Dave gentleman's more on the proper
course than then Pat Shermer was and
that's why they made this switch
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports